[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich willkommen was im
Sport passiert ist das erfahren Sie von
Oberkönig in einer Viertelstunde guten
Abend es gibt weitere Strafmaßnahmen
gegen Russland eines unserer Themen
Kampf der Kriegskasse ein höherer
preisdeckel auf russische Erdölprodukte
soll moskauseinnahmen beschneiden
sterben Skifahrer Stürme verschärfen die
Gefahr
und Triumphen Eiskanal Kim kalicki holt
erstmals WM Gold im Zweierbob Lisa
buckwitz jubelt über Silber
[Musik]
Russland soll weniger Einnahmen haben
die für den Krieg in der Ukraine genutzt
werden können das ist das Ziel der EU
und so werden ab morgen keine russischen
raffinerieprodukte wie Benzin oder diese
mehr importiert gleichzeitig haben sich
die EU die G7 Staaten und Australien
darauf geeinigt dass international nur
noch ein bestimmter Höchstpreis für
russische Erdölprodukte gezahlt werden
soll liegt der Preis darüber wird
westlichen Rädern und Versicherern
verboten die Ölprodukte zu versichern
und zu transportieren über den
preisdeckel und das Embargo Maike Weller
das Öl im Bago der EU gegen Russland es
hat eine neue Stufe erreicht nach dem
rohöl-einfuhrstopp will die EU ab
Sonntag auch keine raffinerieprodukte
wie Diesel oder Benzin mehr aus Russland
abnehmen zugleich tritt dafür auch ein
neuer internationaler
preisdeckelingkraft die Obergrenze liegt
demnach bei 100 $ je Barrel für
hochwertige Ölprodukte wie Diesel für
günstigere wie Heizöl 45 $ jeberry
der preisdeckel ergänzt das embago er
hat das Ziel sicherzustellen das
Drittländer noch Raffinerie Produkte aus
Russland beziehen können aber zu
erschwinglicheren Preisen Russland wird
also gezwungen die Länder zum
rabattpreis zu versorgen
nach EU-Angaben kostet Moskau die
bereits bestehende Preisobergrenze für
russisches Rohöl rund 160 Millionen Euro
pro Tag der Schaden dürfte mit den neuen
Maßnahmen noch größer werden unter dem
EU Embargo für Diesel und Co könnte auch
Deutschland leiden und zwar in der
Tankstelle
2022 wurden trotz ukrainekrieg noch rund
12,5% des dieselbedarfs aus Russland
bezogen experten erwarten jedoch keinen
dramatischen Preisanstieg wir sind jetzt
gerade dabei Diesel zu importieren aus
Ländern wie Indien oder Saudi-Arabien
die im Endeffekt russisches Öl billig
kaufen zu Diesel verarbeiten und das
dann an uns weiterverkaufen und damit
ist so gesehen die diese Versorgung bei
uns sichergestellt und gleichzeitig
verdient Putin aber weniger mit dem
Verkauf von Öl der Druck auf Putin
steigt und damit auch die Not andere
Abnehmer für sein Öl zu finden
blicken wir direkt auf den Ukraine Krieg
da haben Kiew von Moskau heute fast 200
Gefangene ausgetauscht so viele wie seit
Jahresbeginn nicht mehr 63 russische
Soldaten wurden zurückgeholt so das
Moskauer Verteidigungsministerium
Kiew spricht von 116 freigelassenen
Ukraine der Austausch von Gefangenen ist
ein Bereich in dem beide Seiten noch
miteinander verhandeln
von Friedensverhandlungen ist man
offenbar weit entfernt stattdessen gehen
die Angriffe von Kämpfe täglich weiter
besonders in der Ostukraine unsere
Reporterin Katrin Eigendorf war nahe der
Stadt rakev unterwegs an der Grenze zu
Russland zusammen mit ukrainischen
Streitkräften die sollen die russischen
Truppen abwehren ein Reportage auf
lebensgefährlichem
Grenze entfernt wir sind unterwegs mit
einer Einheit der ukrainischen
Territorialverteidigung nur in ihrer
Begleitung können wir uns hier aufhalten
sie beschießen uns hier ständig gerade
hat man mich benachrichtigt dass eine
orlandrone in der Luft ist die führt
Aufklärungsflüge durch normalerweise
beginnt dann eine Stunde später der
Beschuss deswegen ist es gefährlich wir
bleiben hier nur kurz dann gehen wir in
den Bunker
der Kommandant will mir gerade die
letzten Raketen zeigen die hier
einschlugen da geht es los
wir müssen schnell in den Schützengraben
unter der Erde warten wir während
draußen Artillerie Feuer zu hören ist
und die anderen Männer sind Zivilisten
sie haben sich freiwillig gemeldet für
den Einsatz an der Front doch gut
ausgerüstet sind sie nicht
westliche Waffen würden uns sehr helfen
Panzer Mörser Artillerie
Verteidigungswaffen
Schützengräben wie hier durchziehen das
Grenzgebiet auch hier wird der Krieg um
die Ukraine entschieden mit Waffen wie
diesem alten sowjetischen
Maschinengewehr
in Sichtweite von hier
sind die russischen Stellungen die von
dort hier auf diese Position permanent
feuern
auch hier wie überall im Land rechnen
Sie mit einer russischen Offensive noch
im Frühjahr doch darauf das wollen sie
uns hier zeigen seien sie allen
Problemen zum Trotz vorbereitet
ein möglicher spionageballon belastet
fast Verhältnis zwischen Washington und
Peking nun hat das
US-Verteidigungsministerium nach eigenen
Angaben einen zweiten Ballon über
Lateinamerika entdeckt man prüfe ob er
ebenfalls china gehört der erste Ballon
ist mittlerweile über die USA Richtung
Osten geflogen
US-Außenminister blinken bezeichnete den
Vorfall als unverantwortlich und
inakzeptabel China verletzte damit
internationales Recht
Peking hatte die spionagevorwürfe
zurückgewiesen es handelte sich um einen
forschungsballon
nach Deutschland eine gesunde Ernährung
Sport keine Zigaretten all das kann das
Krebsrisiko senken sagen Medizinerinnen
und Wissenschaftler zum heutigen
Weltkrebstag
bei uns erkranken jedes Jahr rund
510.000 Menschen neu am Krebs besonders
häufig im Alter zwischen 60 und 79 die
gute Nachricht jeder zweite Erwachsene
kann geheilt werden bei Kindern sind es
sogar 80 Prozent der Grund dafür sind
ständig neue Behandlungsmethoden
mit einem Beispiel aus Bochum
am 19 Mai 2021 lässt Günther Funk eine
Darmspiegelung machen er hatte etwas
Blut im Stuhl an Krebs denkt der
59-Jährige nicht doch dann direkt nach
der Untersuchung die Diagnose Darmkrebs
im fortgeschrittenen Stadium saßen dann
abends gemeinsam am Abend Essenstisch
und haben uns schon gefragt
warum ich warum nicht früher zur
Koloskopie gegangen warum ich warum
diese Erkrankung Günther Funk ist heute
fast zwei Jahre später krebsfrei dass
das so ist liegt auch an einer neuen
innovativen Diagnose und Therapieform
Liquid biopsy die flüssige Gewebe
Untersuchung das Prinzip Tumore setzen
winzige erbgutteilchen frei die im Blut
zirkulieren diese Erbgut Informationen
können Aufschluss darüber geben wo sich
Tumorzellen entwickeln Ärzte können dann
schneller reagieren und so oftmals
schonender behandeln
setzt meine Liquid biopsy-test ein dann
reduziert man den Anteil derjenigen
Patienten die nicht Chemotherapie
überhaupt erhalten das heißt weniger
Chemotherapie weniger Belastung für den
Patienten bei gleicher Rückfallrate
und die Krebsforschung geht noch weiter
derzeit wird an einem mRNA Impfstoff
gegen Krebs gearbeitet die ersten
Schritte sind gemacht und die Ergebnisse
machen Hoffnung den Krebs in Zukunft
noch besser in den Griff zu kriegen
Früherkennung hilft im Kampf gegen Krebs
aber nicht immer sie kann auch zu
unnötigen Behandlung führen
Informationen hierzu haben wir in der
App und auf ZDF heute zusammengestellt
mit Einschätzung von Fachleuten unter
Antwort welche Untersuchungen von der
Krankenkasse übernommen werden
es gibt eine wachsende
Gewaltbereitschaft der Reichsbürger
Szene warnt Generalbundesanwalt Peter
Frank die Behörde gehe von etwa 23.000
reichsbürgern in Deutschland aus
größere Teile dieser Szene sind zu
aktiver gewaltbereit oder äußern ihre
Gewaltfantasien gegen staatliche
Repräsentanz freier als früher sagte
Frank der Welt am Sonntag
im Tarifkonflikt mit der Deutschen Post
gehen die Streiks weiter viele Briefe
und Pakete bleiben in den kommenden
Tagen voraussichtliche
Nordrhein-Westfalen liegen in Essen
legten heute etwa 400 Beschäftigte die
Arbeit nieder bis Dienstag sollen die
Warnstreiks auf das ganze Bundesland
ausgeweitet werden so die Gewerkschaft
sie fordert angesichts der hohen
Inflation 15 Prozent Melonen für die
rund 160.000 Beschäftigten
in Hamburg haben Demonstranten gegen
eine Koranverbrennung protestiert mit
der rechtsextremen Schweden vor zwei
Wochen internationale Empörung ausgelöst
hatten zur Kundgebung der Innenstadt kam
rund 3.500 Menschen dazu aufgerufen
hatte eine islamistische Gruppe die laut
Verfassungsschutz für die Errichtung
eines Kalifats kämpft und als
verfassungsfeindlich eingestuft wird
wie werden geflüchtete untergebracht im
500 sehlendorf Upahl in
Nordwestmecklenburg sollen bis zu 400
geflüchtete in einer Containersiedlung
unterkommen in der vergangenen Woche bei
einer Kreistagssitzung dazu kam es von
der Tür zu Protesten und Krawallen unter
anderem von Neonazis und die Lage zu
entschärfen von gestern Abend eine
Bürgerversammlung statt eine Stadt fällt
war dabei
strenge Ausweiskontrollen am Eingang der
Bürgerversammlung in einer Sporthalle
rein dürfen am Abend nur Anwohner aus
Upahl 400 sind gekommen die meisten sind
gegen das geplante Containerdorf in
ihrem Ort für hunderte Flüchtlinge
hauptsächlich aus Syrien und Afghanistan
die Opera fürchten sich vor Kriminalität
ich habe Angst um unsere Kinder unsere
Großeltern das wird ja alles die ist nun
mal so ne das da haben wir halt Angst um
na das ist wenn das wirklich viele junge
Männer sind die haben Langeweile die
wissen nicht wohin es ist nichts in
Unfall die Masse ist dagegen muss ich
erstmal sagen zu guter letztes Jahr so
in der Größenordnung wie es sein soll
ist es halt zu viel der Kreis
Nordwestmecklenburg muss per Gesetz bis
zu 30 neue Flüchtlinge wöchentlich
unterbringen Landrat Tino Schumann steht
mächtig unter Druck Unterkünfte hat er
keine mehr appelliert an die
Bundesregierung wir brauchen die
Ressourcen wir brauchen das Personal wir
brauchen Liegenschaften wir brauchen die
Betreuung wie soll die Integration
stattfinden das Ehrenamt wenn sie sich
auch zusehen davon ab am Rande der
Bürgerversammlung protestieren etwa 100
Menschen lautstark gegen das
Containerdorf unter ihnen auch
Rechtsextreme rund 120 Polizisten sind
im Einsatz
drinnen reden die Opera Klartext mit den
Verantwortlichen die Angst vor
steigender Kriminalität hält
Innenminister Pegel für unbegründet
gemeinschaftsunterkünfte erhöhen nach
den Zahlen die der Polizeiinspektion
seine mitgebracht hat hier im Landkreis
Nordwestmecklenburg wo es eben schon
eine Gemeinschaftsunterkunft gibt gerade
nicht signifikant sind die jeweilige
Kriminalität
ab Anfang März wird das Containerdorf
errichtet allerdings vielleicht kleiner
als geplant darüber wird in der
kommenden Woche verhandelt
monatelang irrte ein maroder
Flugzeugträger voller Giftstoffe über
dem Atlantik nun hat Brasilien das
Kriegsschiff im Meer versenkt die rund
60 Jahre alte Frau Paulo sei
kontrolliert geflutet worden teilte die
brasilianische Marine mit ein
Alternative habe es wegen der Schäden am
Schiff nicht gegeben
Umweltorganisationen zeigen sich
schockiert das Schiff besteht aus
mehreren Tonnen Asbest und anderen
gefährlichen Materialien
in Chile sind bei Waldbränden mindestens
13 Menschen ums Leben gekommen das Land
leidet seit Tagen unter einer Hitzewelle
und 200 Brände halten die Feuerwehren
Atem mehrere Häuser wurden zerstört
hunderte Menschen mussten in Sicherheit
gebracht werden die Regierung hat in
einigen Gebieten den katastrophenzustand
ausgerufen um dort Soldaten gegen die
Feuer einsetzen zu können
sehr viel Neuschnee und Sturm diese
gefährliche Mischung macht gerade den
Menschen in Österreich zu schaffen in
den Bergen lösen sich Lawinen gefährden
Dörfer und Skifahren und Skifahrer die
sich abseits der gesicherten Pisten
bewegen es gab schon drei Tote Britta
hip hat mit einem Überblick
grias die Schnee endlich lang genug
haben sie in Österreich darauf gewartet
doch bis zu einem Meter Neuschnee in
Kombination mit starken Wind sind am
Berg extrem gefährlich besonders für
Skifahrer 30 Lawinenabgänge allein in
Tirol an elf Abgängen waren Personen
beteiligt wir haben jetzt genau so eine
Situation wo wir immer Bauchweh haben
die Gäste kommen viele Leute unterwegs
endlich einmal Schnee aber jetzt
wirklich wir haben eine gefährliche
Situation der Venen lassen sich leicht
auslösen Lawinen gehen auch von selbst
ab selbst Überschätzung ist oft mit
unterwegs in den letzten 48 Stunden
mussten Rettungskräfte häufig ausrücken
um Skifahrer zu retten die abseits der
Piste verschüttet wurden für einige kam
jede Hilfe zu spät
in Vorarlberg unterbrachen sie die Suche
nach zwei verschütteten sogar wegen des
Sturms auch für die Retter ist es dazu
gefährlich der Wind ist deshalb so
gefährlich weil er Gefahrenstellen
überdeckt ja die man so im Gelände sonst
erkennen kann aber auch der Nebel die
schlechte Sicht verdeckt Gefahrenquellen
und da muss man besonders aufpassen wenn
man unterwegs ist vielerorts herrscht
Lawinenwarnstufe 4 der Sturm knickt
Bäume und Strommasten um manche Orte
sind immer noch von der Stromversorgung
abgeschnitten auch die Zufahrt ist
mancherorts gesperrt der Sturm soll
nachlassen bis morgen aber ein paar Tage
Vorsicht ist auf den frisch verschneiten
Bergen dringend nötig
und jetzt kommen wir zum Sport die
Fußball-Bundesliga mit Toren in Hülle
und Fülle und einem neuen Tabellenführer
Norbert ja genau und zwar mindestens
noch für 24 Stunden also morgen um diese
Zeit diese Spitzenposition hat sich
Union Berlin redlich verdient mit dem
fünften Sieg im fünften Pflichtspiel
2023 dem 2:1 gegen Mainz 05
seajös
Siegtreffer viel für die Köpenicker in
der 84 spielminute Dortmund gewinnt das
Spitzenspiel gegen 10 Freiburger 5:1
Frankfurt mit 13:0 erfolgreich gegen
schwächelnder hertana Leipzig verpasst
Platz 2 0 zu 0 in Köln 7 der 19
nachmittagstreffer fallen in Bochum beim
5:2 gegen Hoffenheim am Abend Gladbach
gegen Schalke gestern Augsburg gegen
Leverkusen 1:0 morgen um etwa diese Zeit
wissen wir ob sich die Bayern in
Wolfsburg die Spitzenposition
zurückgeholt haben
so eine Tabelle wünscht sich der
neutrale Fußballfan nur fünf Punkte
trennen Union Berlin und den neuen
sechsten SC Freiburg das breite
Mittelfeld reicht vom VfL Wolfsburg bis
hinein in die untere Hälfte zum FC
Augsburg Bochum kann noch auf den
Relegationsplatz 16 zurückfallen Schalke
bleibt definitiv letzter das Abendspiel
der Schalker in Gladbach ausführlich im
Aktuellen Sportstudio um 23 Uhr zu Gast
die drei Hockey Weltmeister grambusch
Wellen und Torwart Danneberg
klarer Erfolg für Tabellenführer VfL
Wolfsburg im Spitzenspiel der Bundesliga
der Frauen das souveräne 4:0 beim
Tabellen vierten SC Freiburg besiegelt
Lena Latein in der 87 Minute der 11 Sieg
im elften Saisonspiel für die
Titelverteidigerinnen
und Aufholjagd erfolgreich beendet Kim
khaliki und Angie Brin Leonie Fiebig
sind neue Weltmeisterinnen im Zweierbob
Kim kalicki rechts und Leonie Fiebig
Siegen in St Moritz mit einem
Wimpernschlag vor einem weiteren
deutschen Duo
ganze 500 Sekunden ledigliche Vorsprung
nach vier Läufen nach den ersten beiden
lagen sie noch auf Rang 2 die dritte
Deutsche Pilotin stürzt Olympiasiegerin
Laura Nolte bleibt aber wie Anschieberin
Nele schuhten unverletzt
im Viererbob der Männer führt nach zwei
von vier Läufen das deutsche Team um
Francesco Friedrich mit vergleichsweise
komfortablen 20-100 Vorsprung
Karl Geiger erreicht beim Weltcup
Skispringen in Willingen Platz 5 beim
achten Saisonsieg von Überflieger Halver
gerade Rüth Katharina Althaus kam
dagegen nach einem fantastischen zweiten
Flug auf
149 einhalb Meter knapp unter
Schanzenrekord ihren fünften Saison Sieg
bejubeln die Oberstdorferin verdrängt
immer klinetz aus Slowenien und Sarah
Takanashi Japan noch auf die Plätze 2
und 3
Alexander Zverev hat den vorzeitigen
Sieg für Deutschland in der Davis Cup
Qualifikation gegen die Schweiz verpasst
nach dem Erfolg des Doppels mies und
Pütz verliert Zverev in Trier mit zwei
zu sechs und sechs zu sieben gegen Mark
Andrea Hüsler der schon sein erstes
Spiel gewonnen hatte Zwischenstand 2:2
wäre im Wert zum Finalturnier nach
Malaga reisen darf entscheidet sich
zwischen debitant Daniel Altmaier und
Stan Wawrinka
das sind viele Namen ein Ziel im
November nach 30 Jahren endlich wieder
die hässlichste Salatschüssel der Welt
nach Deutschland zu holen Apotheke
[Gelächter]
jetzt erstmal die Daumen
wir können auch zum Wetter morgen kommt
aus Westen neuer Regen und Schnee auf
mehr zum Wetter gleich von Christa Abend
um 22:45 Uhr können Sie das heute
journal mit eine sehen auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
ja guten Abend mit einem stabilen hoch
gibt es nächste Woche viel Sonne vorher
schummelt sich morgen aber noch eine
Front über das Land und die bringt auf
ihrer Vorderseite Schnee auf der
Rückseite Regen das liegt unter anderem
daran dass es im Osten zur Zeit auch
kühler ist heute Nacht minus 7 Grad bei
Aufklaren im Bergland strenger Frost bis
minus 10 Grad im Westen bleibt es bei 6
Grad wir kommen in der zweiten
Nachthälfte auch die Regenwolken auf mit
leichtem Regen die vor allem im
schleswig-holsteingebirge im Westerwald
schon Schnee bringen können im Süden
gibt es Nebel im Osten klar ist auf
deswegen hier auch vormittags
aufgelockerte bewölkerung mit Regen im
Westen macht sich aber die Front breit
zwischen der Ostsee und dem Schwarzwald
kann dann schon schneefallen teils bis
in tiefe Lagen insgesamt ist das nicht
allzu viel nur in Stau lagen kommen zum
Beispiel im Rothaargebirge um die 10 cm
vom Himmel nachmittags machen sich die
Schneeschauer dann auch über den Süden
und erneut an den Alpen breit im
Nordwesten da trocknet es aber ab und
der Tag klingt sehr sonnig aus mit der
Front frisch der Wind aus Norden auf
bringt an der Nordsee Sturmböen im
Westen dazu drei bis acht Grad kühler im
Osten mit nur noch -2 bis plus 2 Grad am
Montag zieht sich dann diese Reste der
Schneeschauer in den Südwesten zurück
spätestens ab Dienstag setzt sich aus
Osten trockene Kaltluft durch mit
frostigen Nächten und sonnigen Tagen